herr ernst wenn sie das hören was die
analyse angeht die militärische analyse
auch eben dass die truppen zu geschwächt
sind und es jetzt dazu kommt dass oder
sehr wahrscheinlich dazu kommt wenn
erdogan sich am ende dazu bereit erklärt
dass viele donato aufgenommen werden was
bedeutet dass aus ihrer sicht wäre das
erste mal bedeutet das ja festgelegt
wurde auch bei den abkommen dass man
gesagt hat kein land so ist ein die
sicherheit auf kosten eines anderes
eines anderen landes erhöhen und
selbstverständlich wird putin dies als
problem begreifen
welche entsprechen mein name ist ernst
ist es ich bin jetzt dran so und es
bedeutet dass jan ist natürlich
als einen akt begreifen könnte der seine
sicherheit bedroht ich denke nicht dass
dies dazu führt dass putin in finnland
oder in einem anderen land der nato die
dann in der nato werden angreift ich
glaube auch nicht dass er mit
militärischen mitteln des verhindern
wird das ist ja auch nicht tun aus
meiner sicht aber das problem ist ja
dass die frage müssen wir sie mal
stellen alle miteinander werden durch
diese schritte wird europa durch diese
schritte ist sicherer oder ist es eher
eine weitere stufe die uns auseinander
treibt und die damit risiken in der
zukunft bringt und das ist meine meinung
ich denke die zukunfts risiken werden
doch so einen halt größer und nicht
kleiner also ich finde es richtig dass
man das alles abwägen und bedenken muss
weil wir tatsächlich in dieser situation
nicht sagen können was ist jetzt der
richtige schritt ich möchte die gehören
ja zu der einheit wie 2008 verhindert
haben dass die ukraine in die nato
aufgenommen wurde warum sind sie jetzt
dafür damals hatten wir nicht nur wir
sondern auch andere bedenken davor dass
wir eben diesen schritt unternehmen ohne
dass es seitens russlands ein anlass
dafür gegeben hatte damals 2008 jeden
fehler nach immer an den sieg glauben
wahrscheinlich glaube dass auch eine
stärkere rüstung der ukraine vielleicht
das risiko für putin das zu erleiden was
er jetzt erlebt hat auch sichtbarer
gemacht hätte und wir so vielleicht auch
ein angriff verhindern hätten können das
haben die amerikaner demokraten wie
republikaner jahrelang gefordert wir
haben dagegen gehalten weil wir der
meinung waren militärisch weil man das
nicht eskalieren aber ich möchte eine
these hier
komplett widerlegen aus meiner sicht ich
glaube das protein sich die nato
überhaupt nicht bedroht fühlt 0 bedroht
wird das ist die legende die er erzählt
mit der meint sein volk auf putzen zu
müssen gegen andere staaten wie zum
beispiel ukraine denn wenn er
tatsächlich sich von der nato bedroht
fühlen würde würde er nicht einen großen
teil seiner streitkräfte dieser
vergleichsweise strategisch und
wichtigen ukraine frage investieren
würden seine generale ihm sagen du musst
die truppen bereit halten für den fall
dass die nato die gelegenheit nutzt und
uns angreift und einer damit rechnen
muss braucht er auch keine angst davor
zu haben das findet in der nato kommt
hat er auch nicht er hat keine angst vor
der nato das ist eine legende die er
seinem volk mama ralf stegner der ja als
ein politiker galt der besonders häufig
platini putin verteidigt hat und das was
in russland passiert ist und ich habe
nicht ein einziges mal verteidigt weil
ich keine sympathie für autokraten habe
ist ein kriegsverbrecher werde nach den
haag ich gehöre allerdings zu den leuten
die sagen das sind spekulationen man
muss teilweise sich in die perspektive
von anhängern versetzen auch wenn man
deren perspektive nicht teilt putin hat
sich getäuscht hat sich getäuscht in der
nato dies mitnichten hirntod wie beim
smartphone gesagt hat sondern die hat
sich zusammengefunden die europäische
einheit ist so groß wie sie schon ganz
lange nicht gewesen ist hat er sich
getäuscht hat sich getäuscht in den
militärischen zielen trotzdem ist
spekulation an sondern auch die russen
sicherheit bedroht fühlen oder nicht bin
kein psychologe ich weiß dass nicht ich
kann nur sagen wir sind also freundlich
ruhig leuten im orient und sagen wir
wissen das aber telefonieren sie
manchmal mit leuten die wissen wie man
weiß nicht was soll nicht über uns auch
was die fahnen gesagt ich würde mich
gern mit dem kubanischen botschaft
streit ich hab das gegenteil gesagt ich
habe sowieso eine innenpolitische
diskussion nicht mit botschaftern führen
das nicht deren aufgabe sondern diesen
diplomatie machen wir streiten
untereinander mir was ich würde sie dann
auch aus russland von ihren früheren
kontakt muss sagen ich kann nur sagen
dass es das bedrohungsgefühl gibt auf
der einen auf der anderen seite das kann
man nicht wegreden mit rationalität weil
bedrohung etwas objektives und ich bin
das beispiel nennen was in der
konzentration an das war aber trotzdem
einem was verrät auch keine idee hat
gelernt das hat damals nämlich den
dritten weltkrieg verhindert in der
kubakrise gegen den rat von journalisten
wissenschaftlern
militärischen und wirtschaftlichen als
politischer zeit bestand das ist wichtig
ist wenn man in der außenpolitik mit
gegnern zu tun hat dass man nicht ihre
perspektive teilen muss dass man aber
nachvollziehen muss wie die denken
könnten das hat keine idee getan hat
eine sehr kluge haltung trug sind nicht
die die die wildesten interviews geben
club sind nicht die härtesten forderung
haben so klug sind die die einerseits
unsere freunde verteidigen ob sie ein
leben durchaus mit interviews und
andererseits 40 und andererseits darauf
achten dass auch die sicherheit des
eigenen landes der bundeskanzler ist
vereidigt schaden vom deutschen volk
abzuwenden
das tut er was die bürgerlichkeit nennig
besonnenheit die bürger auf der straße
finden das uns auch gut da können sie
reden so viel sie wollen sich die
umfragen an die berliner nach hagen
heute so haben morgen so werte sind in
den
usa so dass ich jetzt erzählt der bürger
wurde das goutieren
ich weiß wir auf die auf deutschen
straßen unterwegs sind aber wenn sie da
sind und leute schauen mir die relativen
umfang an umfragen die beratung steht
sie auch dass die mehrheit der bürger
die das ist auch schon die nachricht
doch nicht allen ernstes oder vor 20
jeden fall hat er ja recht dass die
mehrheit der bürger gegen schwere waffen
für die ukraine sind jedenfalls diese
für besonnenheit und wenn sie dafür wenn
sie genau hin und wenn sie genau
hinschauen und gehören hat selbst der
kanzler gesagt hoppla wir müssen
aufpassen also ich würde eine klaus das
kölner steht nach einem anderen einsatz
privater von maximal 1
märz im kanzleramt oder den stoiber im
kanzleramt oder gar kanzler und dann
sage ich ihm die antwort lautet und
davon und er sorgt erstmal wir machen
hier keine vorbilder oder an dieser
stelle ganz kleiner 1090 wir müssen
aufpassen ist könnte zu einem atomkrieg
führen besorgen kann als automobile hat
er das stichwort ich möchte einmal